thank you very much for coming here
today I'd like to horse tank all in the
hoodies hun and Beth for putting this
all together agreed to be back at my
alma mater today I'm going to talk a
little bit about a one aspect of my
current research which in some ways came
out of Mayan character with mackie no
son I research on the history of
Japanese film theory now a way way back
when when I wrote my dissertation my
dissertation project which eventually
became the book visions of Japanese
majority was concerned with how cinema
was defined shaped and our key
articulated in its first 30 years in
Japan the argument was that cinema did
not simply arrive fully formed in Japan
in 1896 what was created over time in
part by discursive processes as the
often conflicting efforts to describe
and understand cinema in various fields
ranging from criticism and law to
philosophy negotiated an established
films place in E modernizing japan yet
obtaining these discourses was not an
easy matter for me other people have
talked about similar problems it was not
easy especially when it came to the
period before the rise of the medium is
a mass phenomenon a point when the
volume of writings on it naturally
increased libraries often did not have
such material so I relied on a kindly
gentleman you offered me access to his
collection of rare materials at home
Latino my moto now one of the early
books he showed me wasn't work with the
curious Japanese title Shoku hi big aku
published in 1911 by a man named
nakagawa she Captain Makino's on when
you talk to him you say nakagawa jus dey
at least in the dictionaries he's
shigeki Mikey no sign explained that
this was the first book in Japan to
consider the cinema from the standpoint
of philosophical aesthetics his copy was
rather pressure
so he wouldn't allow me to do what he
did with other texts as with Joanne and
run down the street and photocopy a
section at the local Colombini so I sat
down and painstakingly copied the one
chapter naka girl wrote on film this may
have been rather ironic since I actually
eventually learned that nakagawa
argument was that art involves a
creative transformation of reality and
that then and thus that such slavish
reproductions a reality which is what I
actually considered cinema was doing
we're not to be considered art now my
copying was certainly not created though
my handwritten kanji were pretty
atrocious but I was copying was clearly
an important step in establishing the
question of film art and thus in
defining the medium maquinas on saw in
nakagawa an issue of cinema that most in
Japan had ignored the beginning of a
long and complex history of intellectual
conceptualization of the motion pictures
now although Mike knows on also does a
devoted considerable energy to the study
of documentary and censorship one of his
main concerns was the history of film
theory he wrote about a number of
crucial figures who wrote mon film
ranging from the psychologist tottenham
kanji to the poet sugiyama haji but he
particularly focused on what he named
the kyoto egg Akua the kind of kyoto
school of film after the kyoto kaka the
philosophers who congregated around he
stood up he thought oh at kyoto
university now while many imagine kyoto
is the repository of traditional
japanese culture it was also a center
for film production and a major site for
theorizing cinema and its relation to me
guarantee Makino includes in the egg
Cochran such important mines is nakaya's
a casa toni collette it says oh who's
the father of tiny collection
the poet shimizu quadro kono Yukichi and
a guy in each star Oh mostly active in
Kyoto nakagawa figures from machi know
as the start of this long connection
between Kyoto and film theory in a
symposium honoring lucky no son and his
collection I thought it very appropriate
to consider the work of nakagawa shiki
aki and the issues they posed for the
history of Japanese commentary now is
tempting to narrate a history of
Japanese film theory by locating its
roots in pre-modern Japanese aesthetics
but just as the cinematic apparatus came
to be defined discursively over time in
relation to transformations in modernity
so film theory was subject to complex
negotiation between foreign and domestic
discourses that was reflected and
attempted to negotiate with the modern
if film theory had a relationship with
aesthetics it was primarily with
European philosophical aesthetics
nakagawa shigeki was an early nexus of
this relationship since he was one of
the central figures introducing German
aesthetics to Japan in the late meiji
era and it was in particular his
interest in the work of conrad langa
that led him to pursue the question of
whether film was an art long does
conclusion that was not an art along
made him the object of disapprobation by
later film theorists wishing to distance
themselves from his ideas nakagawa
agreed with longer but the peculiarities
of his situation and is thinking I
contend actually reveal much about the
dominant ways cinema would be
philosophical ossified in subsequent
decades in japan now born in 1850s the
son of a samurai Tokugawa was a somewhat
typical Meiji man mixing ambition with a
renaissance perspective and a dedication
to improving Japan he learned poetry
from massive ishiki and founded Kyoto's
most influential poetry journal ok are
we his pen name as a poet was in fact
nakagawa she may now round 1890 he began
translating works by German estheticians
eventually earning a teaching position
at a new art college in Kyoto his
greatest contributions to aesthetics for
his two books
settings of hiking and aesthetics of
detached contact shall go I be back what
I just mentioned earlier both of which
were primarily devoted to explaining the
allura hi chi or haiku poetry through
western aesthetics and in the end
nakagawa exhibited in a not a typical
relationship to Western philosophy his
focus on hike I could be aligned with
okoko detentions called for return to
Japanese artists yet aesthetics of hike
I begin with his declaration that it
that his is quote a form of aesthetics
that uses haiku as an illustration uncle
now Koga with us treads the fine line
between using high goop to explain
Western aesthetics and utilizing your
being philosophy to clarify the
principles of Japanese poetry yet as
Canada tomio describes it this
ultimately manifests a quote tendency to
approach all forms of Japanese art from
the point of view of European aesthetics
and regard them as objects of aesthetic
speculation Japanese works are just
being valorized and foreign aesthetic
principles themselves thereby rooted in
concrete domestic examples but is still
the Western gaze and its own notion of
contemplative distance that defines
Japanese art as art nakagawa was
concerned about this foreign gaze
however and wrote articles introducing
the often mistaken views of Japan
evident in the Japanese fashionable in
Europe at the time yet he was never the
agitator agitator Okakura was he could
be upset about the obtuseness of Modi
all guys translation of Edward von
Hartman and thus proudly gave aesthetics
of hi KY the subtitle quote in plain and
popular words on road but that reflected
less his resistance the activation of
aesthetics that would eventually render
his own eccentric contributions outmoded
than his dedication to the major
enlightenment spirit if his basic aim
was to quote unify European aesthetics
and traditional Japanese thought unquote
it was to a certain extent because of
his background
in the Natural Sciences and is made you
believe in the universality of both
science in part as it means for Japan to
catch up with the west and aesthetics
Wichita Kagawa should always in some
measure be a scientific discipline now
as maca gawas character as a Renaissance
man that made him open to new phenomenon
it has been said that he had a modern
sensibility that understood the
avant-garde now I'm lucky don mackay no
son himself in his research on nakagawa
has argued that matsumoto matata role
who was actually one of the pioneers of
experimental psychology in japan and
also the dean of the art college where
nukka gawa worked that he was an
important stimulus or influence on
nakagawa introducing some of these new
things that knock agha would then go on
and pursue so it should not be
surprising that that in the aesthetics
of detached contact he took up the issue
of the motion pictures neck I was
approached to the medium however was not
fact new itself in fact much of the
section reads practically like a
translation of a similar section in on
cinema in the second edition of Conrad
long as the nature of art such liberal
borrowings were not uncommon in the
Meiji intellectual world and naka gawas
in particular unfortunately priests ages
the degree to which later Japanese film
theory would depend on foreign writing
but just as with this later thinking one
should not merely dismiss nakagawa as a
mere imitator in the process of him
adopting longer one can see aspects of
selection embellishment and negotiation
that communicate much about the
beginnings of Japanese film theory now
what nakagawa found most attractive in
manga was his aesthetics of illusion
illusion I should say in particular the
notion that artistic illusion is
conscious illusion the impression a
viewer has that a work is similar to
something in reality while always
remaining conscious that it is not the
reality itself that duality and the
corresponding gap between the work and
reality allows for the intervention of
both a creative artistic subject who
does not slavishly imitate reality and
the active spectator who must work to
connect the illusion to real phenomenon
the illusion is not a result of
deception but of individual artistic
creation that does not fool but rather
prompts the viewer to imagine what is
not there what uniquely interests
nakagawa about this is less the problem
of mimesis then the conundrum of
contradiction how to entertain an
illusion without ever really believing
it is this sort of contradiction that
allowed nakagawa first to align longa
with the concept of chakra a detached
contact which comes from a Zen koan that
calls for saunas simultaneously grasping
and turning away from words and reality
second he thought longa picked up or
linked up with another principle
proposed by month old Marshall that
lines in poetry should be neither too
closely connected nor too detached in
other words neither separate nor
attached in Japanese foodie for Socko
these two concepts shahi and foodie foo
silcoon became the central terms in
nakagawa aesthetics and so his attempts
to introduce longest philosophy were
shaped by his understanding of Eastern
philosophy and poetry as a result he
strays from langga whose focus on the
consciousness of artistic perception
does not necessarily relate to such
issues as the connectedness of lines of
poetry a psychological issue has been
rendered spatial or to a certain degree
a concern of logic now go further
interprets longer by repeatedly quoting
poetry from the Masters in the midst of
the discussion finding haiku that in one
way or another illustrate explicate or
Riley comment on the points being made
one can interpret these tactics as nukka
oz efforts to domesticate or japanese
through rooting in the tradition now
this vision of Japanese culture
enveloping an absorbing manga however
should be tempered by a consideration of
how much longers voice not only remains
loud in nakagawa but will remain a
significant presence in japanese film
theory for decades to come even as
knocking ah himself was largely
forgotten longest conclusion and nogales
well is that cinema and other
photographic media is not an art because
it is too close to reality it's illusion
of motion is not conscious its relation
to reality too close while later
thinkers would dispute longest
conclusion about films artistic
credentials they would not question his
criteria concerning what art is if there
is a difference in nakagawa it is
subtler like langga he starts with the
particular inadequacy of motion pictures
quote in contrast to the stereoscope the
moving pictures move in the way reality
does but lack the spatial dimensions of
the sort found in reality when we look
at the continuous pictures projected in
front of our eyes appearing and
disappearing our senses may be fooled
and unconsciously recognized motion but
one cannot avoid the contradiction here
simply put the images are flat and not
three-dimensional unquote this
inadequacy could conceivably be to
cinemas artistic benefit because it
separates from reality and encourages
the spectre to work around this lab this
in fact is how the German theorists
rudolph Arnheim justified film is
already in the 1920s and 1930s back
cinemas platanus lack of color and sound
and other perceptual peculiarities
prompted it to become an art as creative
filmmakers took advantage of or invented
original ways to work around these lacks
in audiences consciously enjoyed such
invention lunga and nakagawa however
felt those inadequacies were too great
to enable film to become an art to
nakagawa quote the pictures betray
themselves in this way revealing the
under the horse costume despite the
perception that the images are moving
because of this our illusion plays
itself out on one side but cannot fully
play itself out on the other it cannot
avoid limping along just appearing thank
ish these were thus only negative
deficiencies ones that failed to promote
creation or even actively discouraged it
far from being a conscious illusion
cinema is not even a very good illusion
the second problem for longer nakagawa
is that such unproductive in
inadequacies cannot even be rendered
productive by following and improving on
the essence of the medium both thought
it logical that sound in color would
become part of the medium and thus light
on the a buzz and that film would
naturally move closer to reality this is
a long quote if it goes that far the
only factors that may prevent illusion
are the method of dispatching the
pictures and the projection of images on
the screen in that case one can have
even less hope of achieving an
impression of art is that not because
although the pictures appearing and
disappearing before my our eyes may have
come that much closer to the reality
that photographs they have thus become
like reflections in the mirror if they
are not they may have the benefit as
with looking through binoculars of
creating the sense of seeing and hearing
things up close they can become the
essential tool of the historian
conveying historical events to later
generations as they occurred but even if
they benefit us by creating a sense of
familiarity one where we seem to really
witness the events there is absolutely
nothing gained in terms of the enjoyment
of artistic taste the individuality that
is characteristic of art fails to
surface and there is no trace at all of
creation in these works one can only
stare and wonder if the mechanical and
mention
and the entertainment of reason the more
it progresses the more its non artistic
illusion grows unquote Tanaka kawa
cinema is this damned both in its
current incarnation and it's
teleological outcome the basis of
artistic illusion must not be a simple
difference between the work in reality
the difference itself must enable or be
the product of artistic play the feet
revealed under the horse costume is just
an error a deformation not an artistic
play of deficiencies if the feet were
hidden the illusion would have been more
artistic but only if it was based on the
simultaneous knowledge that there are
people inside the costume cinema just
freakishly offers mechanical unconscious
illusion combined with obvious in
artistic inadequacy real art as well
sculpture often involves a conscious
choice to remain inadequate to reality
nakagawa again resorts to a poem to
illustrate this point about what art
should be this coming from tong tigey
the no play said not a word the prayers
of me boo in japanese colgan wha nominal
he was a new boom Woodson now the
reference is to of the poem is to the
famous silent note plays performed in me
boo Kyoto every a book called the new
moon in Boots it this can be nautica a
citation of an artistic form that makes
better use of silence than cinema does
which to him seems like a medium that
should have Sam but does not but the
style of the poem is as important as its
content it delightfully combines a
wordplay namitha multi wazoo can mean
both said a word and said not a prayer
with a liberalization of the name of the
place in word sooo by itself can
actually means prayers to the Buddha
Nagar drama the seemingly not only
envisions the contradiction of a prayer
that utters no
earth which is different from a crowd
scene in a film that simply lacks sound
he rebels in the double meanings and
multiple associations that grow out of
this conundrum eze komatsu kiddo she has
underlined the laker longer was not as
negative about these cinemas artistic
possibilities as he and Kagawa
originally were perhaps nakagawa could
have changed too especially if he had
the benefit of viewing the more complex
films that longa later did but they did
not yet exist in 1911 naka go himself
passed away in 1917 yet like even the
later longer he still seems to place
emphasis on what are conceived as
fundamental aspects of the apparatus
ones that cannot be overcome by either
pragmatic application of the medium or
audience reception in this regard
nakagawa sets the precedent for the
essentialism that would reign over much
later japanese film theory but like much
subsequent theory as well and ancient an
anxiety / reception lays behind this
emphasis on the apparatus note that the
connector that nakagawa also places a
key mingle or the living dolls made of
paper mache that were popular at
fairgrounds during the meiji era among
the forms that he does not consider art
as Kinoshita now Yuki has argued fair
ground or temple fair Entertainment's
like Iggy menial called me simona as a
whole in jab in japanese were important
in the introduction of western realism
into Japan a keening yo for instance
we're not only skillfully created but
also presented in a carefully managed
space where the light and the viewers
perspective were arranged to prompt the
illusion that the dolls were alive that
Gaga were complained of such efforts
such as the choice to give realistic
color to the beginning yo a choisi
underlines that artistic sculptors
review
he seems most disturbed about the
practice of placing the dolls in a space
not clearly framed by a pedestal but
rather quote on the same level as the
viewing audience on every day to tummy
mats as if they were part of mundane
reality it is this choice to promote if
not forced the impression of reality to
make the viewers forget that they were
just viewing an inanimate object that
disturbed nakagawa such efforts place a
key nino on the same in the same
category of non art as the motion
pictures the fact that the two even
though one depends on crafting
manipulations of paper and light and the
other on mechanical devices and
emulsions are both seen is too close to
reality indicates that nakagawa is
echoing the dominant discourse of the
day first which up until the nineteen
ten solving cinema not as a separate
medium but actually is part of the
larger rubric of the same oh no by that
time audiences were already being shown
in movie theaters scenes from kabuki
play is complete with kabuki music and
Vinci imitating actors voices that is as
an illusion of a kabuki play in a manner
similar to beginning yo illusions now
the case of Vicki Mingo however shows
that the problem of excess reality is
not simply a matter of mechanical
manipulation but also involves the
viewer whose gaze is part of the
apparatus that makes the dolls seem
alive aqui Nina go as a medium that
crucially depends on the audience or is
a medium that crucially depends on the
audience to complete its illusion of
reality yet in determining that such
miss Amano are not part nakagawa appears
to presume that the audience somehow
loses full consciousness that pic paper
mache and the case of other reason
bamboo figures were not living beings
dr. Howard could not conceive of film
spectators then as consciously and
actively working with the difference
between a flat black and white image on
screen and a three-dimensional colorful
reality in other words he could not see
me say Mona or film audiences as
enjoying the playful artistry of on
their own making one thing one thing
seem like something it is not of taking
pleasure in consciously being part of
the transformation art Tanaka gawa is a
conscious illusion created by the artist
one that shuns trickery even if such
tricks are accompanied by a willing
suspension of disbelief or a conscious
appreciation of the trick one gets the
sense that his distinction between Arts
and non arts is not merely a matter of
their different apparatuses and
practices but also his conception of
class and spectatorship who is better
able to consciously and intellectually
entertain in artistic illusion or who
has the class not to desire a deceptive
illusion of reality in reality these
differences may actually involve
differences in taste and culture that
reflect social and class conflicts in a
modernizing Japan nakagawa reaction to
cinema and miss a mano if not also his
promotion of the field of aesthetics was
a means of promoting one culture in a
struggle with other biomol cultures at
the time one that ties one that tries to
bridge scientific modernism with
traditional poetry while remaining wary
of lower class cultures already with his
work film theory as well as some
practice participants in a field of
conflict / class and culture now if we
then albeit problematically begin the
history of Japanese film theory with
mark
chiaki it is a history colored from the
start by apprehensions about film that
are tied to worries about class and
culture nakagawa however is a figure who
reveals if not rebels in contradictions
in this endeavor as he entertains the
realism of cinema but rejects its excess
reality as he four grams of illusion but
down plates trickery as he focuses on
apparatus but worries about reception
his focus on contradiction is intriguing
it makes us wonder whether there might
be a cinema that is foodie fuzhou coo
attached and detached as a zen colon
where shots are edited so that they are
neither too late nor to separate one can
ask whether this vision is in fact not
really modernist well at the same time
still finding links with the Japanese
past nakagawa in fact provides an avenue
for later figures like inagaki tato hole
the novelist and who was one of the few
to continue writing on film through
nakagawa concept of soco Heidi gaku
detached contact to essentially has
criticized the development of the
invisible techniques of classical
Hollywood cinema in the end Linkin what
wonder whether nakagawa himself is not a
case of foodie few soku as he treads the
line between following European
aesthetics and interpreting it through
the Japanese poetry he knew as he
embraces contradictions but still
attempts to move them towards a
particular cultural outcome is perhaps
that aspect that makes nakagawa both
unique within the history of Japanese
film theory and an important precursor
to those who followed him the Kyoto
yokai coma and perhaps Makino mamota
himself thank you